uma das coisas que sempre falavam desde
novo é que eu era diferente de todo
mundo e eu comecei a perguntar sempre
será que realmente eu sou diferente
sei que me via como qualquer adolescente
de quase 18 anos
eu não consegui entender por que que eu
era diferente quando eu tinha 12 anos de
idade
eu tive o primeiro contato com a
programação e que ele me encantou de uma
maneira incrível era como consult vai
ser encontrada nesse mundo parece algo
simples algo bobo e aprendo cena época
programando arduino eu me encantei por
isso eu descobri que ele realmente é a
minha paixão e desde então eu comecei a
entender algumas coisas e eu descobri
que eu gostava de aprender não só sobre
robótica e programação inteligente
oficial mas também sou física quântica
neurociência economia e eu comecei a
entender e buscar apenas sobre isso e o
atual momento que a gente vive a a
cuidar da internet é a gente tem essa
liberdade de conseguir aprender sobre
diversas coisas em todos os lugares que
a gente quiser e desde então eu não
conseguia também entender porque que
alguns amigos meus de pessoas do meu
mundo social também não gostava daquilo
que eu estava porque meus amigos da
mesma idade que a minha não gostava
também de programar e eu comecei a
perguntar eles não gosta de programar
porque eles realmente não gostam porque
eles não tiveram oportunidade de
aprender alguma coisa a aprender a
programar aprender algo
e desde e assim eu comecei a imaginar
sobre como vai ser o futuro e começar a
entender se é sobre as relações de
pessoas que já começam a gostar muito
novo sobre elas gostam e pessoas que não
tá passa uma vida inteira sem conseguir
realmente descobriu que elas amo fazer é
e com todo esse as palavras que eu botei
sobre boxe e inteligente oficial robôs
autônomos
a gente tem diversas tecnologias hoje
ocupando cargos
nos setores das pessoas e tecnologia
será que realmente elas vão um dia
substituir humano e pensando nisso tudo
eu comecei a me perguntar se é que
realmente eu preciso de um diploma
eu pensava sobre o que eu tenho pra
escola principal escola para poder
aprender mas aprendendo o jovem na
internet na minha casa no conforto do
meu quarto
só quando consegui entender que a
relação entre você ir para a escola ela
passava muito mais além de você aprender
em siglas também ter relacionamento com
pessoas e com isso eu comecei a me disse
algo dentro de mim assim não conseguiu
entender muito bem com digerir isso e eu
comecei a sobre as profissões sobre eu
preciso me informar eu preciso é ter que
ir para a faculdade eu preciso eu
preciso ser igual a todo mundo e o
controle um exemplo é esse é um produto
que tira bactérias e odores de camisa e
de roupas usando nanopartículas e
incrível porque você consegue ficar com
a mesma camisa durante uma semana sem
precisar lavar e você pensa sobre se a
quem criou esse produto foi um cientista
maluco e aí você imagina qual seria a
profissão dele é um químico designer de
moda e eu aposto que esse produto e
design de moda
só que o que fez um design de moda e lá
e que é um produto desse o produto x é
15 produtos que gera um grande impacto
que com algo simples consegue quebrar
tudo uma indústria toda uma cadeia
milenar sobre tecidos e uma judia se
você precisa parar de lavar roupa ou
então eu falava com menos freqüência ou
então você precisa parar de consumir
roupa porque se você não lava no gasto
você não consome e olhando tudo e é
pensando você entende sobre a revolução
maker e revolução maker mês que vem da
bola fazer e fazer coisas é não você
começa a pensar eu vou fazer o quê se
conhecer você começa a buscar
conhecimento você tem problemas e tudo e
símbolos de informação
você pensa que um cinto de se consegue
quebrar toda uma indústria que consegue
realmente sim
hoje graças ao momento
toca a gente está passando a gente tem
tecnologia suficiente para qualquer
pessoa hoje aprender sobre qualquer
assunto e poder criar coisas que
impactam no mundo
gente isso é real isso existe isso está
nas nossas mãos
só que quando você a gente entende que
está passando uma geração de mudanças e
isso é muito bom você sentir isso
essas mudanças são muito boas você
consegue saber que você pode aprender
que você pode construir
você pode fazer coisas de impacto no
mundo você pode ajudar pessoas e isso é
muito importante
só que essa geração de colaboração
a gente tem o open source a gente tem
diversas coisas hoje que as pessoas
começaram a haver maneira diferente a
gente tá muito mais colaborativo a gente
quer compartilhar coisas a gente
compartilha a informação conhecimento a
todo momento e uma das coisas que me fez
pensar sobre isso eu tenho um grande
amigo um grande guru da minha vida das
finais é ele sim para uma coisa que eu
demorei muito tempo pra entender é que
nesse momento que a gente vive hoje ele
vem de encontro ao acordo de paz andres
exemplo a época de 50 e 60 a galera paz
e amor a gente uma geração que precisava
ser alguma coisa você precisava ser
alguém para você conquistar você
precisava ser um uma pessoa pra você ter
diálogo conversa só que logo depois na
geração 70 serão lembrados consumismo
gigante no mundo uma geração que você
precisa consumir consumir consumir e não
importava mas quem você é disse você
tinha você ter alguma coisa passou será
importante
só que ter alguma coisa logo depois você
não precisa mais ter um carro e
simplesmente vai ter lugar uma bmw dar
uma volta na praia e parecia que você
tinha algo só que foi pior ainda com a
geração da internet
você não precisa nem parecer que se
tínhamos armas lugar se tirar uma self e
na bmw parecia que você tinha alguma
coisa só que olhando tudo se passar das
gerações
o que a gente vê hoje a geração z o que
é mais importante é você ser alguma
coisa se tornará seu voltou a se impor
assim é importante
e o confao pessoas e como busquei foi
isso eu queria ser alguém e eu acho que
as pessoas precisam buscar hoje é se
tornar não se preocupar com sua
aparência em se você tem se você parece
nem sei se você ser o seu conhecimento
ninguém tira de você
e olhando todo esse lado de geração
colaboração que muitos galera muita
gente fala hoje
e quando você olha tudo isso você pensa
mais no brasil
será que isso realmente existe no brasil
isso parece que é ao lado de fora de
outro mundo
a gente tem um país que tem 45 milhões
de jovens
só que de 55 milhões de jovens 25
milhões deles estão fora da escola e
mais 50 por cento deles são de baixa
renda e mais de três milhões estão sem
emprego
só que quando você começa a entender a
estatística desses dados porque com
jovens estão fora da escola
mais de 50% deles não tem mais interesse
e você se pergunta a jovem não tem
interesse em aprender
quando a gente olha o jovem de baixa
renda hoje no perfil é a gente viu nos
últimos anos eu tive oportunidade de
rodar ou muitos lugares do brasil
entendendo sobre jovens e eu comecei a
vir jovem na minha idade mais novo do
que eu é que precisava para estudar pra
botar comida dentro da mesa para ter o
que comer quando chegasse em casa
esse é mais na maioria da população
brasileira dos jovens é assim eles não
têm oportunidade de aprender mais todo
momento que a gente está passando de
revolução tecnológica que oportunidade
de aprendizagem
ainda assim exigente que é obrigada a
parar vim aprender por não ter
oportunidade e olhando isso você começa
a pensar com o sonho do jovem
o jovem que ser da vida em que o jovem
intensa para o futuro dele e vou trazer
um caso exemplo seja mais realista para
a gente
quando você olha o perfil do jovem
brasileiro que não está nas estatísticas
com apresentei em si o jovem padrão
jovem que é é a melhoria
e quando você olha um jovem tradicional
você olha linha um jovem de 15 a 18 e 19
anos ali que quer da vida
ah eu quero cursar biologia mas é só
puxar biologia quero saber hoje uma
universidade federal e é esse alguém
tiver de biologia vai conseguir entender
seca quando você entrou pra cursar
biologia no segundo semestre ali você
via tudo aquilo que você aprendeu
durante o ensino médio
e você perguntava tudo o que eu aprendi
aqui não tem nada a ver um com aprende
na escola
só que é que realmente você aprendeu na
prática o jovem falou 'pai eu quero
largar o carro trancado quero mudar de
curso ao pai fala você é maluco você que
estudar é o meu sonho aqui que realmente
aprendeu na prática sobre teologia ou
sobre as matérias que seja quando você
olha a nossa educação de ensino médio
educação básica a gente é muito mais
focado em teoria a gente tem pouca
conteúdo prático e olhando tudo isso a
gente consegue entender o quanto jovens
hoje em dia estão formados e não
consegue ainda assim o unidade no
mercado de trabalho e olhando isso você
pensa que a educação não prepara o jovem
para o futuro
a educação está preparado para os jovens
terão algo teórico e mas na verdade quem
importa se você tem experiência sobre
aquilo
e esse caso de teoria experiência seu
muito real
a gente vê pessoas formadas com
doutorados e mestrados que não consegue
ocupar cargos no mercado hoje
e você consegue com mais toda a economia
que a gente está passando a gente não
consegue encontrar muita gente talentosa
sem fim com achando que a teoria que ele
sabe realmente não consegue encaixar ele
também olha isso tudo a gente olha o
steam que é sim fica ciência tecnologia
engenharia e matemática são metodologias
de ensino que a gente consegue pecar
hoje a educação básica média para
conseguir levar a experiência para
jovens de educação na massa que
realmente importa é você conseguir a
oportunidade para os jovens mas
realmente aprendem sobre aquilo ali com
sobre coisas muito novo muito muito nova
e isso é uma oportunidade para ele
conseguir descobrir o que ele realmente
gosta e que normalmente é aquela
actividade mão na massa lhe consegue
desvendar muita coisa para ele e
pensando sobre como reconstruir a
universidade
eu lembro quando tinha 12 anos de idade
que era fascinado com este acordo fica
fascinado por neurociência ouvir um som
era conseguir estudar isso com as
melhores pessoas
por mais que tenha internet no projeto
na ufrj
ou então qualquer faculdade estudando
sobre isso e quando a gente pensa sobre
como reconstruir como geral mas essa
oportunidade eu acredito que em vez de a
gente pensar na gente pensa sobre essa
muro e sobre educação básica média
superior a gente deve construir mais
pontes um homem mais oportunidades vamos
tocar uma experiência onde aproveitar
toda essa geração de colaboração que a
gente está vivendo e trocar
conhecimentos conhecimento é a única
coisa que a gente leva para sempre nossa
vida então eu acredito que
compartilhando coisas compartilhando
conhecimento e construindo mais pontes e
- muros entre a educação brasileira
gerando mais oportunidades de jogos que
estão querendo aprender tenho contatos
com tudo isso é uma maneira diferente a
gente conseguir repensar a universidade
olhando tudo isso uma dica que eu queria
deixar para vocês é muitas pessoas não
estão perdidos sem saber elas têm uma
essa essa engenharia social que a gente
vive que você precisa mais ser estudar
ter um trabalho
só que aí vem a gente acaba esquecendo
que é mais importante eo que eu queria
dizer pra vocês é isso busco que você
ama faça o que você realmente ama
será que eu faço o que eu gosto para e
pensa agora sobre isso
será que é isso que eu quero o resto da
minha vida
será que ocultou aprenda agora vai mudar
a minha vida ou vai deixar algo para o
mundo de conhecimento que consiga
melhorar a vida das pessoas
eu queria dizer a isso no final faça o
que você realmente ama bem vindo a
geração z e muito obrigado